We're not talking about the like don't
have difficult people or don't
>> I know.
>> We're describing folks that effectively
hijack
>> [laughter]
>> everything.
>> Yeah.
They create no value.
>> And like
you know who they are. Again, if you're
watching this, we're not talking about
the people on the line where you're not
really sure and they but they've done
all this really good stuff.
>> the word terrorist for a reason.
>> This is where you're like, "Oh, wow.
This is a whole cloud of problems." That
is what we're referring to.
>> Yes. Yes.
Welcome to Dalton Plus Michael. Today,
we're going to talk about
terrorists and startups.
>> [laughter]
>> What the hell am I talking about,
Dalton?
>> Yeah. I mean, look, this was always your
thing. I remember over the years hearing
this term from you and learning from you
where you would talk about terrorist
customers for startups. And so,
obviously
um this is some colorful language we
were using. Yeah, can you just define
what you meant when you
>> It was interesting. I remember talking
to a startup and this startup was trying
to help a customer that was almost
unhelpable to the point where this
startup would have to do things that
would never make them any money. Things
that would only apply to a tiny
percentage of people. And it was almost
like the startup was serving the
customer out of pity versus out of like
even like accomplishing their mission
and goals.
And I remember saying to this founder
like you can just fire this customer.
And I And I remember this founder had so
much kind of emotional tied to this
customer.
And you know, when you're in office
hours, sometimes you have to use kind of
like aggressive language, [laughter]
right? It's like, "How do I How do I cut
this emotional tie?" And it's like,
"This customer is a terrorist. Like,
they are actively bombing your startup.
>> [laughter]
>> You have to let them go." And I think
that that word kind of like
flipped something in their head and they
were like, "Oh, yeah. Like, this
customer is causing my business harm and
that's not we're supposed to be doing
this mutual exchange where we both
improve. We're not supposed to do this
exchange [laughter]
where I die.
And so
I think that's where it came from and
and then lo and behold we have found
terrorism in other areas. It's not just
terrorist customers. I think in terms of
customers if someone's watching this and
they're like, well, how do I know if I
have a terrorist customer? Like, what
are these guys even talking about? Let's
let's give some of the properties.
>> [laughter]
>> So, I think one is
where
they're effectively holding you hostage
yes because they might be such a large
customer. They might be the only
customer. So, a common setup for getting
a terrorist customer is your brand new
startup
and you get some nice inbound from a
really fancy great logo yes and they're
willing to pay you lots of money and
effectively the rest of your startup is
not going well. And so, you have this
one shiny
>> bright spot
>> bright spot when everything else is
going bad and perhaps that customer
understands that they have that leverage
over you.
>> perhaps
>> And you effectively spend the next
duration of your life as a startup
founder catering to this customer yes
and
this might mean your entire roadmap is
dictated by them. It might mean you're
losing tons of money to service them.
>> customer service out the this craziness
yes
>> Basically, they they dominate yes your
existence as a startup founder.
>> And this can happen to consumer
companies
>> and B2B companies which is interesting
yeah.
>> Again, the the point is they have this
leverage over you and there's often
brinksmanship where there's new crises
that that happen because of the customer
that cause you to not be able to make
progress on your startup.
>> Well, I think what's interesting about
this too is that you know, you're
framing it as like
the customer has leverage over you which
is totally true. But I've also seen it
where like you give that customer
leverage. Like they're not actually that
good of a logo. They're not actually
paying you that much. It's just that
you're so desperate for anyone to be
replying to your emails and getting on
the phone with you
that like you just don't want that to
stop. And so you'll do things that have
nothing to do
with your company succeeding.
>> This would come in office hours where
people would be surprised how often
we would be like after someone got into
YC, "Oh yeah, you should like not
service that customer anymore." And
they're like, "But you're We're going to
give up all this revenue. What are you
talking about?"
>> Dalton.
>> [laughter]
>> They're talking to me and I'm like,
"Yeah, you don't want to be in that
business anymore."
>> No.
>> Um I think that's really surprising to
founders sometimes.
>> I think it really is, too. I really wish
startups could reduce down to just like
one variable, which is like grow
revenue.
Uh it just it's not not actually true
and the quality of your revenue kind of
matters.
I think the other thing that's tricky
about a terrorist customer is that I'll
move this to a to kind of like a Let's
say the customer is actually okay.
They're not in and of themselves
terrorist customer, but they're asking
you to do something
that you shouldn't do.
>> Yeah.
>> So let's call that like a terrorist
request. So a terrorist request could be
something like, "Hey, we're asking you
to do some project where you're going to
lose a ton of money, right? Or asking
you to do some project where they're
like, "Oh, like you did this really
great software thing for us over here.
Can you like I guess you're good at
writing software. Can you just like
write us more software over here, here,
here, here?" Or
one of them that's actually like really
tricky is like, "Oh, can you build this
feature for us?"
Where when you really dig down, you
realize that feature will not help the
customer, but they're asking you to
build it. But like you've now spent some
time, you understand the customer's
business, and you're like, "It will not
move the numbers. It will not
What do you do? What do you do when you
have a good customer giving you a
terrorist request?
>> Well, I think you've got to find a way
to say no. Again, this is the the
terminology of terrorist customer is
like you don't negotiate with
terrorists.
>> [laughter]
>> So, so the the point
Uh the point is you have to find a way
to not do it.
>> Yes.
>> And it's up to the founder to understand
the nuance of the relationship. So, I
don't know if I want to give too general
advice on this video of like always just
say no and go away, but
>> you do need to hold your ground and not
get involved. Um because what's what's
funny about these dynamics is once you
start saying yes, it's not like they
stop
with the problems. The problems keep on
>> coming.
>> Yes, and growing.
>> Yeah.
>> One of the mistakes I see a lot of
companies make is they don't understand
their customer well enough to even know
whether they're being given a terrorist
request or not. Their mental model is
customer tells me to do something,
they pay me, I do it, we win.
Instead of their mental model being
I need to do things that makes that
customer's business better or that makes
that customer's life better if it's
consumer. Like
only delivering on those tasks will
produce long-term victory. Delivering on
other things they ask for will not. And
I think there's this embedded assumption
that we've encountered a ton of times.
It was like, "The customer knows how to
make their business better, right?
>> [laughter]
>> Right? Like the consumer knows what they
want, right? Like all I have to do is do
what they ask me to do, right? Don't
>> I [laughter] I think
>> I'm talking to them. They said, "Do
this." You told me to talk to them.
They told me to do this.
>> I think we've talked about this in a
video before, but it reminds me of this
old thing Mark Zuckerberg talked about
>> once when he came and spoke to the to
the batch.
>> Yeah. He would argue with his employees
because they had talked to their
customers and done user research, and
there were all these features that the
customers wanted them to build for
Facebook. And then the PMs were like,
"Oh, we should build these features."
>> Yes.
>> And Zuck would shut all that stuff down
and say the best feature that Facebook
had, like early Facebook, was having all
of your friends on it. And actually
growth is a feature.
And they're not articulating this to us.
We'll This will never show up in in user
research.
>> But we should be spending all of our
cycles on growth of getting everyone
onto Facebook so that all the people are
there. And that's actually the number
one thing we do to increase satisfaction
as opposed to building a long laundry
list of features.
>> And no one's asking for it.
>> Yeah, no one's no one's articulating
that feature. So again, the advice here
is
blindly following feature requests.
It's a It's a leaky bucket. There's a
hole in the bucket and you will never
fill it if you're just blindly following
feature requests.
>> No.
>> You kind of got to synthesize all of
your information from what the customers
are telling you versus taking them
literally.
>> Well, and this was the classic issue at
at Twitch where streamers
when we were pivoting to Twitch asked us
for all kinds of features
and they never asked us, "Can we get
paid?" Because they never thought it was
possible. You don't ask your your dad
for a Ferrari when you're 16. Once
again, we had to use the context clues
and it was tricky. I remember the first
time we got a hint
was when we learned that one of our
biggest streamers, like someone who
could get 50,000 people watching them at
any given time, pumped gas.
And we were like, "Oh. Oh, this is a
>> [laughter]
>> This is a hint. This is a hint. Like
maybe
these people who are good in this area
aren't able to monetize their skills in
the normal economy.
Our bar is not how do we make someone as
much money as an I banker. We might just
have to make them as much money as
someone pumps gas. Like, okay."
>> We used to do surveys for people in the
YC batches about what they wanted. And
if we took that stuff really literally,
we would have spent all of our We would
have spent all of our time
>> [laughter]
>> on food. We would have spent all of our
time hiring increasingly extravagant
chefs.
>> [laughter]
>> If we listened to our users in the most
literal way, that was the number one
piece of feedback we got.
>> What about my nightshade allergy? I had
to [laughter] order DoorDash at the for
>> Yeah.
>> But seriously, that was the number one
recurring feedback we got from YC
founders about the YC program was food
related.
>> Well, and what was really funny, I
remember reading those surveys and it
was I felt like I was hunting for clues.
Like some of the most interesting stuff
would be like these off-handed weird
comments
that like would not be reflected by the
masses, but they'll be like, oh, like
that would have been a better or oh,
wow, like you used something that we had
different than everyone else.
But it was not
you know, build a word cloud and like
like look at [laughter] the biggest
word. Like, no. Oh my god. No, no, no,
no, no. So bad. Okay, so we've talked
about terrorist askers.
We've talked about terrorist requests.
I think for the founder that's far
enough along, they know that the biggest
source of terrorism is from the inside.
>> Yes.
>> Terrorist employees.
>> [laughter]
>> What do they say? Something's on the
inside with the
>> Yeah, they say the call is coming from
the
>> Yeah, INSIDE [laughter] THE HOUSE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT TERRORIST EMPLOYEES.
What
Any experience?
>> Okay, like I don't know I don't know
what you're talking about.
>> So, let's start with folks that aren't
in the company yet.
>> And so, the terrorist recruits.
>> Recruits. The the setup is a founder is
like desperate to hire. It's hard to
hire.
>> Yes.
>> And then someone amazing comes along and
they're like, holy cow, they used to
work at Google, they used to work here,
they were
>> You're like a top 10 in the world at
this thing we need.
>> Um and unfortunately
>> And they want to work for our shitty
startup.
>> you believe it?
>> [laughter]
>> And unfortunately, there's a really
complicated laundry list of demands of
what the person wants around
where they work, how they work, when
they work, you know, just a very
>> weird life circumstances sometimes.
Weird like, well, I can't commit to a
start date or da da da da da. Like all
these like weird things where like if
you were to hear your brother or sister
talk about their like boyfriend or
girlfriend and they would say these
kinds of things you'd be like this is
not This [laughter] is not good. But for
the employee it's like oh but what about
the upside? And so
what happens is you come up with
justifications to say yes to all these
things and ignore the clues.
>> Yes.
>> And then you end up where if you do get
them um it's not like the laundry list
of problems goes away. You've only begun
the process of the person increasingly
coming up with more
>> complicated demands. Yes.
>> And I think what's tricky about a
terrorist employee there are difficult
employees. For sure. And and I worked
with some who were so valuable to the
company. It was incredible.
The thing about terrorist employees like
when you do the P&L the cost benefit
analysis
it is always negative with potential.
>> Yeah.
>> Like no matter how long it's been 3
months it's been 6 months it's been 2
years it is always negative but you
always are like but if I just did da da
da da as opposed to hard to work with
employees
the P&L's always positive.
>> That's a great point. Again this is a
nuanced thing. We're not talking about
the like don't have difficult people or
don't
We're describing folks that effectively
hijack
>> [laughter]
>> everything.
and create no value.
>> [laughter]
>> You know who they are. Again if you're
watching this we're not talking about
the people on the line where you're not
really sure and they but they've done
all this really good stuff.
>> the word terrorist for a reason.
>> This is where you're like oh wow. This
is a whole cloud of problems. That is
what we're referring to.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> A dark cloud.
>> Maybe the meta point and you touched on
this earlier is that
in all of these situations
it is really hard to negotiate your way
out of them.
>> Can't finesse.
>> There's no like
>> Well and once you give basically usually
the solution is I'll give them their
ask.
>> Yeah.
>> And that fixes the problem right? And
the problem
>> [laughter]
>> is there's
it's an invitation to get more asked?
>> Yes. Over and over and over again.
>> This is why we use the word terrorist.
Like this is the definition almost,
right? And I think that um
what's hard especially in office hours
is that usually you and I will pick up
on this pretty fast and be like cut
bait.
>> Yeah.
>> And then we'll do the other office hour
like 3 months later and it'll be like
well for 3 months we didn't cut bait and
just got punched in the face and now
we've cut bait. And you were right and
it was like
you don't deserve terrorists. This is
hard enough without terrorists.
[laughter]
Like
>> Yeah.
It's almost like it's hard
to admit that it's a sunk cost. Like it
there's like this moment where you have
to be like this is a sunk cost.
>> I just need to
>> get out of the situation versus coming
with justifications that it'll get
better.
>> Or assume somehow that like success
comes from dealing with terrorist
situations.
>> Yes. And
>> maybe one other aside um this comes up
with investors too.
>> Oh fun.
>> terrorist investor
>> Never be terrorist Dalton. Don't you
>> I think the classic one is someone that
wants to take up a lot of time of the
founders.
>> Yes.
>> And by the way they may be very nice and
they may not realize they're doing it.
>> Yes.
>> But effectively you get a bunch of
emails or requests or questions
and so the founder spends a lot of time
line by line answering the questions
>> Yes.
>> and guess what they get?
More questions.
>> [laughter]
>> And they answer those questions and they
get more questions and you actually end
up spending like a huge percentage of
your time
talking to an investor effectively
managing their feelings
>> on a 15-year journey.
>> Yeah [laughter]
and like
there's no upside. You can't bury them
in so much time they stop asking for
your time.
>> Fundamentally their feelings are based
not on the work you're producing for
them but on is your company working?
That's the only way to change their
feelings. I think there's actually an
even worse type of terrorist investor
and there's a type of investor who's
lost faith
in the founder. I think sometimes
investors don't realize and I've
probably made this mistake a couple
times where it's kind of like you can't
help but be kind of a father mother
figure for this person in a weird way,
right? And like the worst thing a parent
can do is be like, you know, it's not
going to work out for you. Like that's
like [laughter] the worst like you know,
it's like it's like
That is the worst thing. And and like,
you know, your your brother and sister
might be like, I hate my god your gods.
But like when it's your parents, it's a
problem. And I think that sometimes
investors don't realize that they're
just communicating
pessimism.
>> That's such a great point. I think about
this a lot where I've seen a lot of
people critique our advice slash my
advice
>> Yes.
>> um over the years of like don't give up
>> yeah yeah yes.
>> And they're like, oh, why is he so
stupid? Like this whole don't give up
thing like blah blah blah blah. And it's
not that I think they're wrong. I just
like no, I I I have no apologies for
encouraging people to not give up and
encouraging people to stay I still
believe them believe in them. And even
if it is going bad, I do say are you
having a good time?
>> Mhm.
>> And as long as you're having a good time
and you
it's fulfilling the work that you're
doing
don't give up.
>> I think this has been the hardest thing
for me in Off the Record. I think
my personal KPI for Off the Record when
I started was like, does the founder
feel good at the end?
>> Yeah.
>> And that produces zero value. And
when people have overheard me giving Off
the Record, they're just like
you sound incredibly critical or like
you're talking about the things that are
like the biggest problems in the
company.
And
it's this weird balance to try to talk
about the hardest things, but to
communicate like I believe in you.
>> Yeah.
>> It's this very weird balance and it's
like
to me like that's what a great advice
giver give cuz it's like if they're not
a great advice giver if they're not
talking about the most important things
in the company. And if it's a startup,
those things are going wrong.
>> [laughter]
>> For sure.
Some number of them.
But they're also not a great advice
giver
if they're not communicating faith. And
I think like PG actually did this really
well. Like he would you know, he would
have these things like if you just
figured out a couple things, you could
be the next Microsoft. And he would say
it and you'd be like, "No, I can't." But
then like
maybe.
>> [laughter]
>> Well, and you know what the secret is
knowing PG as well as we do.
>> Yeah. Is he actually believed it? Yes.
>> [laughter]
>> And so the trick
>> Yeah. So again, the trick is sometimes
startups work.
>> The trick
to help people by inspiring them is to
actually believe they can succeed.
>> Yeah.
>> That's it.
>> And you can't fake that.
>> Nope.
>> Trying to pretend like you're a
someone's fan and you're not, not likely
to work.
>> Probably better to not
give them advice.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Probably better not to talk. If
you can't believe, yeah. Even if you
know everything they need to do to win.
>> [laughter]
>> So, we've covered customers, we've
covered requests, we've covered
recruits, we've covered employees, we've
covered investors. That's a lot of
Terrace.
>> [laughter]
>> Um
Dodge them. Get Get Dodge them.
>> Don't negotiate with them.
>> Don't think that if you give them an an
inch, they won't take a mile. They will.
>> And don't think that these people will
significantly impact the success of your
company. Like the these are not the
folks that determine whether your
company wins or loses. These are just
>> potholes to avoid on the road. Like
steer around them, keep going.
>> Great shot.
>> Cool. Thanks, Michael.